you
[Music]
my name is Gideon Mendel's I'm the CEO
of common ml as Simon mentioned we like
to say that we do for machine learning
what github did for code
well our machine learning teams to
automatically track three data sets code
experiments and models before call made
I actually started my career as a
software engineer but I've been focused
on machine learning and deep learning
for the past five years I was a grad
student just a few buildings away from
here at Columbia where I was working on
speech recognition specifically building
speech recognition models on low
resource languages where we have little
data and deception detection which is
essentially building a lie detector
using machine learning both on acoustic
and lexical signals after that I spent
some time at Google where I did deep
learning research on hate speech
detection I'll actually spend more time
on this in the talk because I think
there's really interesting learning from
that time and in my previous company we
built an app called GroupWise which is a
chat analytics app where a user-centered
chat history from whatsapp viber line
and get a bunch of entertaining metrics
like who talks about sports politics
with the funniest and so on and we get
to deploy about 50 machine learning
models in production and for those 50
they want to production they're probably
5,000 that didn't and today's talk I'm
going to focus on running effective
machinery teams common issues challenges
in solution I'll focus more on the
workflow and the tooling because that's
where we believe the problems are
so the agenda for today's talk just very
hard to see here I'll cover some some of
the advances we've seen in deep learning
recently and I'll share a case study
from my time from my teams at Google
working in hate speech detection and
then I'll address the main problems as
we see you name around visibility
reproducibility and collaboration I'll
just start try to resize the screen here
all right perfect
so everyone's talking about the deep
learning revolution and they're
definitely we've seen some significant
improvements in the academic world but
sometimes it's hard to distinguish
what's real hype and and what's actual
improvements and indeed a lot of
businesses are challenged and having a
hard time extracting business value from
their models I'll try to walk you
through the advances we've seen in
recent years to try to give you idea of
how impactful the burning was or is so
the first example is image net for those
are you or familiar or not familiar with
that image net is a data set of about 18
million images from anything from common
objects to breeds of dogs it has a
thousand classes so the underlying task
here is given an image try to detect
which class it belongs to and image that
is a very popular benchmark for computer
vision models up until 2011 we mostly
seen traditional computer vision methods
solving this problem but then in 2012
something interesting happened a modeler
a network called addicts net was
submitted and managed to improve
previously results by 10% and it is a
absolute improvement and what's really
interesting is that the technique or the
algorithm sort of specifically her
convolutional neural network with max
polling wasn't something that was new
even we've known it for about 15 years
before that what was interesting is Alex
net was implementing in CUDA which is a
programming language used to program
NVIDIA GPUs which allow them to train
the network in about 6 days so in a
course of about a year they had time to
improve the network
I can try different experiments
different hyper parameters until they
got this amazing result and over the the
next years after we've kept seeing
improvement improvement improvements up
until in 2016
sorry 2015 Microsoft released ResNet and
actually managed to beat the human
performance on this desk
and since then we've seen more and more
improvements the second data set of
problems I want to talk about is from a
completely different domain of speech
recognition so this is the switchboard
dataset it has above 260 hours of speech
from about 540 different speakers and
the underlying tasker's speech
recognition so given a speech utterance
try to predict the sequence of words and
during the mid 2000 we were kind of
stuck word error rates were not really
going down and pretty much leveled out
and then again in 2012
pretty much the same time alex net came
out the first implementation of dns was
successfully implemented so speech
recognition traditionally has two pieces
and acoustic model in the language model
in this case they were replacing the
acoustic model with the DNN and managed
to improve the result with about 3% so
it's not a 10% we've seen alex net but
still pretty impressive
and then in the next year's the
improvement continued and continued we
started replacing the language models
from hmms to LST ends and then we've
seen systems are completely end-to-end
up until Microsoft again in 2016 managed
to reach human parity and at this point
you might be asking yourself well I've
been using Siri and Alexa it's kind of
hard to say they reached human parity
and I definitely agree I think this
serves as a benchmark or academic branch
work which I understand that
improvements but we have a long way to
go do we actually deploy these in these
word error rates in production so for
companies like Google and and other
companies they have a the resources to
train those models the knowledge to
train the models and the data they're
actually doing a really good job
extracting business value of this so
what this chart shows you
as the number of directories that
contain model description files in the
Google Code repository and you can see
this is growing exponentially and while
this chart ends in around 2016 I'm
pretty confident that that growth
continued and what's interesting is
we're not really seeing a ton typical
academic tests or the others feature
condition here in computer vision but
we're also seeing Google Maps drug
discovery Android and so on so it really
spans the entire product area so we live
in this machine learning pioneer age and
it's really exciting to be part of this
and yet while this academic research has
been super impressive and super
successful the biggest obstacles are
really around our processes and tools so
we think the biggest problems are
invisibility reproducibility and
collaboration and I'll talk more into
depth about them later down this talk
but before that I'd like to share a
quick case study so this is from my time
working on hate speech detection at
Google I'll go a little bit more into
details on the science side the data
engineering and and algorithmic side of
things hopefully they'll give you some
background before we talk more about the
problems so the goal here is detecting
hate speech on YouTube comments
unfortunately if you ever use YouTube
you probably know there's quite a lot of
it so this was very important for us the
underlying scientific stack is
essentially document specification
so given a youtube comment which is the
sequence of words try to detect whether
it contain hate speech or not was just
true or false and at the time or data
set was pretty limited so we only had a
few thousand examples when we already
had a model in production when we
started working on this and the goal of
the project was try to outperform this
and gain better result so excuse me
so if you want to outperform the
production model a good place to start
is what's running a production right and
so I was surprised it wasn't that easy
to answer that question so in order to
answer this question you need a few
things the first thing is is code so
fortunately in this case we had the
training code it was checked in version
control that wasn't a problem after that
you need your training data and yes we
had the training data but we had about
ten different versions of it and we
weren't sure which one was wrong one
used to train the production model so
people tried normalizations clean up and
so on and it was just sitting in a file
system and weren't sure which one was
used after that you need the hyper
parameters so those were your not
familiar those are all the knobs
returned to try to get better results
from our neural network anything from
the number of layers the number of
neurons learning rate and so on and so
on
in our case originally the high
programmers were fed as command-line
arguments when the script was originally
executed and they were just completely
lost once we train a model you get two
things on the other end one is your
model binaries or your weights and we
had that because that was running in
production that wasn't a problem and the
second thing is the results so we
managed to find the result it was in an
email sent to the team but we only had
accuracy so we didn't know precision
recall or other data points that might
be useful for us so as you can hopefully
this starts to give you an idea of how
challenging this is now we managed to
rebuild this training pipeline based on
those pieces we collected and retrain
the production model again and indeed we
got oh sorry
before that let's let's dive a little
bit more into the details I assume this
is a more technical crowd so I don't
usually cover this but it might be
interesting for you guys so what was
actually running in production we use a
combination of two techniques
Herrig effectors and an SVM so paragraph
vectors is unsupervised
from text if you're familiar with war
two vet or word embedding it's the
natural extension from the word level to
the dock
and the underlying assumption there or
the idea was even though we only had a
few thousand examples that were labeled
we can train this thing in the entire
YouTube comments corpus and hopefully
get a better result and once we we had
that paragraph vector model trained we
can generate features for later training
for our label dataset and feed it to an
SVM as themes are kind of known to
perform pretty well on small data sets
so overall this this made sense so we
built this entire thing we retrained it
and we actually did get the same result
we saw in the email so the 95 percent
accuracy if you worry the data was
balanced so the random selection here is
50/50
so we're doing pretty well here now once
we have that in place we figure out
what's the next step and how can we do
better now commonly when we work on
those kind of problems you try out you
try and establish some kind of baseline
so usually a baseline is a pretty simple
model something that's cheap to Train
usually has easier easier to it to
understand it and so it has some
explained ability built to it and it
gives you some idea of how hard this
task is right so what we use and if you
ever worked on NLP or documented
suffocation this this technique
shouldn't surprise you we used engrams
which is a way of again generating
feature from text so engrams just
quickly if N equals wants are we talking
about unigram so you basically replace
the word with an ID from the vocabulary
if N equals 2 you replace pairs of words
and so on and so on and at the end of
the day you get a feature vector that
you can feed into your classifier
addition we spent a little bit more time
on this and added some more feature
extraction methods so stemming which is
a way to reduce your dimension your
feature dimensions so basically you can
you can map multiple words to the same
ID so in this case processing and
process will map to the same word
because they have the same stem
additionally we added words stop words
removal which is usually the most common
words in
the vocabulary and the language so
things like with our at and so on they
provide very little value to the
classifier and finally we add a tf--idf
which is a way to normalize between long
comments and short comments so again
this are these are thing that are pretty
simple usually I think they teach them
in like NLP 101
so a typical baseline model in this case
so we train this thing and at some point
we actually started being something
that's pretty interesting we're beating
the production model with our Engram
baseline model right so here we have a
pretty fancy deep learning technique
that's getting crushed by logistic
regression a linear models been around
from like the 70s and we did try or
someone did try baselining this task
before but they probably haven't spent
as much time as we did and trying to
just optimize it so just something to
consider when you try deploying deep
learning networks it might worth it to
try simpler models before that but
nonetheless we were encouraged that we
can get a better result here so we
figured what can we do next is there
anything else we can try and in this
case we went through the scientific
literature we did a literature review
and at the time there was a paper on one
of the actually first success successful
papers on using CNN so pretty much the
same thing that Alex that was using but
for text classification and this was a
paper by Jung Lee too and one of the
fathers of deep learning up until
recently led Facebook AI Research
Institute and what was really compelling
for us as you can see here they actually
tried engrams and well I got a pretty
good result but they managed to beat it
with on continents so figured this looks
interesting we should probably try it as
well so we implement our own CNN that
was pre care uh Sarah
we had to write the whole thing from
scratch and we trained in our data set
and we're kind of disappointed so we're
still beating the production model but
we're behind our engrams baseline model
right and at this point we're asking
ourself okay what what's going on what
can be the reason and we figured it
might be two things here one is we have
a bug in our CNN implementations if you
ever try to implement one you know
there's a lot of room of error for error
and deep burning networks are
notoriously hard to debug so it's not
like you can run every unit test and
just okay this all all tests are passing
and fine so bug was on at one option the
second option is like well we're looking
at different data set right the paper
was using the Yahoo data set some
academic data set and the underlying
distribution could be different so we
might have just locked out and our task
is a little bit different but in order
for us to figure out if we do have a bug
we figure the only way to do this was
actually running at on the original data
set from the paper and in the optimal
world we would have that available but
we actually email the author and ask for
access to their data set and they were
super kind and they share that with us
and we got the data set we fed it
through our pipeline we trained them all
up with our CNN and out of the other
side same result as the paper gut so
this 71.2% accuracy is exactly what was
reported in the paper so so far so good
we probably don't have a bug or maybe if
we do they have as well and the the
second option if you remember was
working we're looking at different data
set right this is this Yahoo data set
we're looking at our hate-speech data
set we just might as well walked out and
time to move on but you know just right
before we wrap this project up we
figured what happens if we take the data
set from the paper and feed it into our
baseline logistic regression optimized
model and I see some of you smiling so
as you might have guessed we actually
managed to beat the cnn's in the paper
with engrams right so well the senior
and resultant paper is completed
reproducible it took some time to figure
it out and really read through the paper
and emailing the author and we did
manage to reproduce it but the engrams
result wasn't and it's not because they
did something wrong they probably just
spent less time optimizing it which is
completely natural but we spend months
we're just chasing this problem and
going back and forth trying to figure
out what's going on how can we do better
than this and if we only had visibility
to what was going on both to our
production models and whatever was
published in the paper things could have
looked very differently so I've said
visibility I said reproducibility what
does it actually mean so we define
visibility is the ability to access view
and react to machine learning processes
and deliverables so things like what's
running a production what's what's my
models performance can can I do I know
what type of parameters was used
do I know what dataset was using what
version was it and another aspect aspect
of this and sometimes it's not clear
when you first look at this is what
happens when you're one of your
colleagues or someone of your data
scientists quit or leave the company or
leave to another team even so they build
so much intuition on understanding of
the underlying problem and when they
leave everything they know goes with
them there's just no way to keep track
of that and when you think why
visibility is so hard there's a few
things the first thing is that the
pieces required are just completely the
couple and happen in different parts of
the process and even across different
teams right so you might have a business
analyst pulling the data for you with
some query and then you pass it to a
researcher that tries different
algorithm the different hyper grammars
and then at some point you might pass it
or a software engineer that tried to
make it more efficient and productionize
it and then at the end of the day you'll
productionize it and you'll have devops
taking care of it now
the other aspect is just there's so many
tools and everyone likes you during
their own favorite machine learning
library their favorite cloud provider
and people feel very heated about this
and it's hard to build this visibility
when all that knowledge is spread across
tools and languages and cloud providers
and finally is just outdated
documentation so most themes do try to
solve this problem by having like a
Google Doc or a wiki and try to document
their work but the problem is is
completely separated from the actual
process so in software engineering we
have this notion of auto-generated Docs
so you have comments in the function and
you have some system that produces
documentation from it and even there
there's problem with comments becoming
outdated but here those documents or
there's wikis or just completely
separated so three months into the
process no one's maintaining them
anymore and they're pretty much useless
so once you have a better idea of what
visibility is and maybe you managed to
solve it you have to go to the next step
and that's reproducibility and there's
there's very heated discussion in the
academic world of what's reproducibility
some some people say that are the finish
and is replicability so just for the
sake of this discussion all the find
reproducibility is a way of having a
recipe of multiple steps running through
those steps in the same order and
getting to the same result some people
would say that you need to have
different recipes that give you the same
conclusion so you can say what I'm
talking about is replicability I'm fine
with that but in machine learning I'm we
think it's pretty much the same thing so
what's the barriers to reproducibility
some of it connects to visibility but
there's also other challenges here so
the first thing is just changes in data
right someone might have updated your
training data even if you're reading
from the exact same file so I'm gonna
touch tit and changed it and then you
will get different results once you
finish training your model you can have
different random seeds so the beta is
shuffle differently and things look
different again inconsistent hyper
parameters so like we've seen in our use
case we didn't have the actual hyper
parameters so even though we got to a
similar result it wasn't
exact same model third there's
challenges and even if you have the data
right in the code ride and the whole
thing set properly if you're running the
same model on different versions of
tensorflow
you might as you might get different
results so that's another challenge
there's also things like inherence the
cache data in some of the neural network
models such as dropout layers and just
difference between how CPUs or different
platforms or GPU run through the same
instruction so you might get some
variability there and then the last
thing is collaboration
so we speak to a lot of machine learning
teams but mostly it's just a group of
lone wolf standing sitting in the same
room and honestly it's very hard it's
very hard to do it otherwise because
there's no way to share the information
there's no way to having a constructive
discussion the easiest way to
collaborate it is having calling someone
hey can you look at my screen this is
what I'm saying so it's really hard to
collaborate and you can imagine if
you've seen software teams once you once
you figure that piece out things really
start moving so at this point you might
be asking yourself this sounds about
true but I know this tool is called git
and it's really great and you should you
should really check that out and indeed
most companies try to solve this problem
with version control or get originally
when I encounter it so kit is an amazing
tool and it's super flexible and there's
like a million ways to do everything on
git so I'll just walk you through one
example of how you might use git to
solve this and hopefully you'll get a
understanding why it's not the best
solution so I've a set of commands here
I don't have any more code on my slide
so that's it
but basically what I'm doing here so
I'll try right so I'm checking out a new
branch and I'm naming it was some kind
of an experiment name I'm then calling
my Python training script and seeding in
the path to the data set my learning
rate so that those are all hyper
parameters and I'm actually really
careful so I'm saving
in textile the model finish training and
I'm adding the results to the branch
committing it and pushing it so so far
it seems like I know what the code is I
kind of know what the data is and I
might even know what the results are but
once you start doing this after a few
weeks and you go to github for example
you see something that looks like this
so on the left side I just have a list
of branches and I have no idea what what
does that even mean
even if I try to name them with more
semantic meaning it's pretty challenging
and then on the on the right side so I
might have multiple training Script in
the same directory and that's that's
pretty common use case and I have this
results but worried it actually comes
from it's it's really hard to answer
that question and again you could be
very careful and try to connect all
those pieces but it was just not
designed for this use case and when you
think about it all those tools will be
building anything from our IDE the
syntax highlighting all those things
were designed for software engineering
workflows so in a typical software
engineering workflow and I know there's
there's a lot of variety of how
different companies do this as a
software engineer we develop something
when we feel like we're ready we commit
it it gets built by I see ICD system it
gets unit tested by tests we wrote in
some other people wrote and then it
might reach sorry
it might reach staging and then by some
kind of return on it will eventually go
to production but if you look at the
machine learning pipeline and I have a
scary slide coming up but it's really
really different and I don't know if you
can read through it but I'll just give
you the the basic idea so here on the
web side I have some data sources could
be databases could be my BI system and
I'm pulling data from various sources
and combining it I'm cleaning it up I'm
normalizing it and then at some point I
might try to do some augmentation or
some fancier stuff on it
after that I'll build my train test and
validation data sets so those are pretty
critical if you want to have the right
process scientifically
here I'm actually running the learning
algorithm so that's really the only
piece that's pure code it's getting fed
by the training set and then later
evaluated but another script or the same
script that feeds in the validation set
and then testing again and finally might
be traduction but usually those models
are connected some kind of KPI so you
don't want to deploy them in GA mode
right away so we might do some maybe
testing check it against our previous
model and so on and so on until
eventually actually reaches production
so hopefully that gives you an idea of
why this process is just very very
different so you might ask yourself what
does the ideal solution looks like and
if you if you take one thing from
today's talk is whatever you decide to
build something internally or buy
something it has to be automated if
you're going to require yourself or
other data scientists to manually tag
and label and document every step of
their process your BOM to fail because
machine learning is an iterative process
it has a lot of intuition into it and
you want to actually allow data
scientists to move faster and not slow
them down and we talked a little bit
about tools and all those things and
different infrastructure providers so
you want something that works with all
of them because if you're forcing them
to use this is the system you're using
yes it might work for some of the cases
but very quickly you'll find people
trying you know new architectures or new
libraries and then you'll lose the
information around that and what what we
find with that is once you figure out
reproducibility you're actually going to
get a lot more than just that kind of
like by definition when you have a
system of record you can do a lot more
things on top of it so one of them is
collaboration which we covered briefly
second thing is comparison comparing
different machine learning models I mean
it sounds like something that's very
important to do but so hard like if you
have two branches how do you compare
them but it's only the code and so on
and so on
the second thing is increased visibility
so not just between the team but also
for managers and execs and so on and so
on and finally once you have a system of
record of all your experiments you can
start conducting meta analysis so that's
where it gets really exciting from a
data science perspective you can start
to try and understand the problem space
the hyper parameter space and I have a I
have one chart that hopefully will give
you some idea of how that might look
like so what this chart shows you I'll
try to walk through right so every axis
here is a different hyper parameter
every tick is a value of that high
parameter and every line here is a
different experiment the more orange the
line is so this is the range the better
the accuracy or validation accuracy is
so just by eyeballing this just look at
this area here I can tell that if I set
my kernel size to five I tend to
outperform all make up my other models
so all this region in my parameter space
is is not I don't need to explore it any
further and there's no way for you to be
able to obtain those results and
information if you don't know all those
lines so all those experiments so a
comment we really think that in the near
future those processes and tools will
become standardized a lot of machine
learning teams look like what software
teams look like 15 years ago and we
think your adoption as a data scientist
as a manager as that organization who
really impact how well you're managing
to extract value from machine learning
and how well can you use machine
learning as a competitive advantage I
think I'm done thank you so much if you
have any questions feel free
[Applause]
yeah that's that's sighs yeah I agree
that's a good choice for another
baseline model we might have tried that
possibly yeah
naive Bayes or a little aggression
recipe and in that sense there you're
trying to establish a baseline they're
all good pics
yeah so I tried really hard not to make
this a sales pitch and try to give you
some value but just so happen to be that
that's what we built a comment from all
those learnings and we try to solve that
for teams and companies yeah so tracking
changes in data is very challenging
because it could be anything from
tabular data to petabytes of images and
especially things like diffing data or
just keeping checkpoints and versioning
what we found out that it works as a
midterm solution is taking a hash of the
data so you at least know that if you're
looking at two experiments and you're
comparing them that they were trained on
different data sets we might you might
not know what line change and so on but
this year no you're comparing things
that shouldn't be comparable
simulating
in exchange she underlines change very
monumental person's whatever selfish
pursuit
exactly
yeah so you're I think you're referring
more to the production side of things
and monitoring models yeah so things
like feature corruption because you
might have a data engineer somewhere
else other side of the building they
change something in the ETL and then you
model start receiving the features and
different ranges or something like that
and then starts basically providing
false predictions so by looking at the
prediction or plotting the prediction
you might have a good idea of this model
start to predict you know once much more
than it used to so it's a good way of
monitoring it yeah all right I think
we're done I have often sorry another
question
yeah so get again it's not the best tool
for this there's something called git
LFS large file system that allows you to
check in bigger datasets
most companies we see store datasets in
s3 as just as as Bob's yeah
exactly yeah so that's some versioning
data set is super challenging to solve
it in the general use case if you're
just operating on tabular data you might
have some solutions out there I think in
the open source world but if you're
using so it really depends reading
vision or audio and so on
[Music]